>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> I'm Stacie Moats, I'm
the Education Specialist
for the Library's Interpretive Programs Office,
which is the office that handles all aspects
of exhibitions, and related programs.
So, the first thing when people come to the
library they almost always are first of all,
astounded and their breath is taken
away by the Jefferson building,
which is an incredible historic building.
If you've never been here, you can actually
experience it virtually online as well,
but I strongly urge you to come and do the
real thing, because there's just nothing quite
like being here onsite in D.C. When
you're in the Jefferson building though,
after you've had a second
to hopefully take it all in,
and perhaps either do a self-guided tour, or
to, you know, go on one of our Docent-led tours
through the Visitors Service
Office, that's when we hope
that you also go through
some of the exhibitions.
And again, depending on your interest, depending
on your time, you can explore the galleries.
Museum Education, a lot of people
don't realize is a whole entire field,
so I actually first became interested as a
kid, and a lot of the research will show you
that you know, if you are in a family that ends
up going to museums, there's a strong change
that you know, you're going
to go to museums as an adult.
And for me that kind of was the extreme in that
my family was extremely committed to going to,
it seemed at the time, every historical
site and museum on the East Coast.
Which I had to admit I did not
always appreciate as a kid,
but certainly led to this lifelong love
of learning, and for informal learning.
I think probably what really drove me to
become a museum educator, and particularly here
at the library was because I just
love all different kinds of object.
And the library as you hopefully know,
has everything in its collections,
it's not only books, but you
know, photographs, films, audio.
I mean, just everything you could possibly
imagine, and it's wonderful to be able to draw
from these world-class collections, and
to help people to understand this history,
not only the United States,
but really of the world.
And so, you really can't ask for a better place
to work, and to have that opportunity to people,
you know, help people connect to the
stories of real people of the past,
and then connect it to things going on today.
For me, it's probably most gratifying when
I am working with teachers or students,
and you see that light bulb go off.
And you see them kind of get this understanding
of wow, like I am looking at the real thing,
this is not, you know, this not just a copy.
This is not -- you know in our world today where
everything seems to be, you know, born digital,
or something that's not authentic in many ways.
They are getting a chance to actually
see something that is one of a kind
that witnessed history, and that's just
for a lot of students something that kind
of blows them away, because they just
haven't really thought about that,
that something has survived,
you know, from that past.
I am truly one of the luckiest people
on the planet, I just think that working
in this institution, working with
the exhibitions, being able to engage
with visitors of all ages, all backgrounds.
You know, people come from all over the
world to experience The Library of Congress,
people are so appreciative, and so interested,
and really amazed to see what we have here.
And then to go online, and to see the
online exhibitions, I'm also the, I guess,
technically the Ask a Librarian
for our online exhibitions,
and that the inquiries come through me.
And so, again, it's great to see how
people use the online resources as well,
but for me being in the gallery
is just -- I could spend all day.
And it's hard sometimes actually to
come back to my desk and do some more
of the administrative end of things,
because I love just interacting
with people of all ages in the galleries.
>> This has been a presentation of The
Library of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.